[Applause]
this constituency by the coast isn't
exactly a tory heartland workington's
support for the conservatives back in
2019 helped the party break down
labour's so-called red wall but the
conditions that help to secure that
victory brexit boris johnson well
they've gone now and the conservatives
need to hang on to constituencies like
this one
if they're to hang on to power
crucial to that would be who leads the
party into the future
pauline goalie put her faith in the
conservatives in the last election do
you still see them as a as a party of
government
i do yes yes sir too
at this present time
again it depends what changes once the
leadership contest is done with and see
where they're actually going to go and
see what they're actually going to do
whoever goes on to lead the tories and
become prime minister needs to convince
swing voters like lee butterworth to
stay loyal
they have to be honest open transparent
to the public
as well as
looking at the problems that we've got
at the minute and that's like the cost
of living massively i like rishi um
juron kovid he's done a lot for business
um he got the furlough system rolled out
pretty quick
but i've lost a lot of trust in him as
well just by association really by
association with boris johnson yeah
what i say of liz like for for me at the
minute we need someone really strong
when i've seen her interact and talk and
she doesn't seem strong she reminds me
of theresa mayer
now that conservative mps have whittled
the leadership race down to two it'll be
up to party members to decide rishi
sunak and liz trust
will be the candidates going forward
this group in the tory heartland of
walton on thames pretty clear who they
support for me it's rishi you know he's
the chancellor that did furlough he's
saved so many people millions of
people's jobs he's saying millions of
businesses he's also actually the one
that's come up with the most realistic
plan rishi's plan is much more
coherent and i think that's something
that members will be able to understand
as and when he gets the chance to go out
and make that case rishi at the moment
has put forward a more credible plan
about around economics but equally i
think that liz trusts will bring some
interesting policies that i look forward
to hearing from her in the weeks to come
in the hustings
the test that the conservatives now
to elect a leader who can appeal to
voters and win elections nick martin sky
news